now for me as the Karpov Kasparov world
championships right really the time that
I came in to chest my maturity watching
those matches and talk about classic it
starts right away good guy bad guy I'm
Rudy focus para immediately right good
good right or wrong right because he's
the young gun going what it looks like
against the old guard right and also
somehow against the Soviet establishment
right maybe it's not the right storyline
maybe it's a little bit of propaganda
but that's what it feels like and he has
come on like a storm and you know
because you played him I mean he was 22
years old competing against this Karpov
guy who has been dominant for nine years
exactly so we have five World
Championship matches between these two
extraordinary chess players who are
extraordinarily different chess players
as well so there is Anatoly Karpov which
to me as a player he's like the pinnacle
of the positional scientific technical
school from Steinitz to bought Vinick to
literally to Anatoly Karpov he is
standing you know on top of the
shoulders of giants and his technique
his practical play he played very
quickly he was just a phenom I mean
where was his weaknesses how do you beat
this guy this guy's just incredible and
then there's this guy Rico Kasparov
character you know a book a page right
out of the am michael tall how the kind
school Alex Claire and chaos chaos chaos
chaos and they did they start their
first match 1984
the rules that you gotta win six you
gotta win six games draws don't count
five five you play to the sixth victory
so you got to win sex and it's like
after nine Karpov is just dominating the
sky he's up like fours em and after 28
games it's five zip five zip I consider
Garry Kasparov a goat V goat the
greatest of all times but he's losing
that first match five zip while he had
beaten other players but he had never
faced somebody like Karpov and Karpov
was making it look easy easy but then
apparently Kasparov made a phone call to
Moscow called up his old trainer Mikhail
Botvinnik who told me how to stabilize
things and make some drawers right and
then we just kept seeing draw after draw
it's 17 straight draw a rearguard a/b
games that were just finishing quickly
and right now the chess world was
wondering right what's going on right
matches past a month two months three
months and we're going what's going on
is anybody ever gonna win this they're
saying Karpov is looking like he said
the door of death itself right wait he's
losing from the stress unable to break
through this youngster and win one more
game right so it was game 32 that's he's
supposed to win I mean he's gonna win
game 32 he has a winning position does
Anatoly Karpov if he wins that game
matches over six it I don't think we
ever hear from Garry Kasparov again
statement really yeah he's lost yeah I
mean it's a it's easy demonstratable
with but somehow Garry saves that then
finally gets on the board with a victory
and then comes games 47 and 48 you just
jumped because I just draw a lot more
draws in between that was the rear guard
action of the 15 16 17 straight draws
that you were just mentioning and then
he put through back-to-back victories
does Garry Kasparov
and now the match is 5 to 3 but it's
gone six months actually it was kind of
funny because do you remember the days
of Ronald Reagan when there were so many
people who were dying in the Soviet
political that he was complaining you
know every time I establish a
relationship with one of the premieres
he dies and they were playing in the
Hall of columns Hall of columns these
big big big columns these big marble
columns where they would bury these
leaders anyway the point was was the
match was being held in this very very
prestigious venue and it went for like
16 months 6 months 6 months I know it's
a long man six months sorry I went
sixteen six months my friend our friend
Jonathan Tisdale was there he only
learned Russian he was like the Reuters
AP guy you know stationed in Moscow you
know you thought he was there for a
chess match he stayed there for six
months and trying to organize such a
match you know give it feed a at least
it's do you're trying to run such a
match and the match never ends you can't
possibly happen
all those drawers when you think about
something like triggering Stein it's for
example jacory versus Einstein it's they
had a match that was 17 games long and
the first 16 games were decisive exactly
one draw one draw was the last game
right guys be to have now have a match
where there's so many draws really did
seem unimaginable exactly exactly and so
there was a big problem there no nobody
is saying there wasn't a big problem but
the match was score was 5 to 3 when the
president of the fidei florencio comp
amana's made a very controversial
decision he annulled the match he just
said that's it matches over we're gonna
play a new match starting at 0 0 but
we're going to go back to the old rules
of 24 games so Karpov of course
protested he said look I'm leading five
to three all I got to do is win one game
Gary says that's fair you know let's go
and then comes the second match
Guerry winds becoming the youngest world
champion in the history of our history
and then that starts a series like we
have never seen and probably again the
same two guys fight for the world
championship five matches in a row
it's whether Karpov has to win the last
game or Gary has to magically win the
last game right in order to tie the
match to keep his title thing you can
imagine I mean they were separated by
something like one game after after all
the matches all the games that they play
their score was that close Gary might be
the greatest player of all time but
there was this one guy who he was not
able to dominate exactly and
statistically it was just a push and yet
having said that stylistically you
couldn't have two more diam
opposed players Anatoly was this
incredible technician Gary this
incredible tactician so you had
basically an immovable force versus an
unstoppable object and the two of them
showed us matches that that will sit
forever in the history of chess with
some games that sit forever as well so
the two of them really played classic
matches vintage matches that will go
down as some of the greatest in the
history of chess